good afternoon everybody my name is John
MIT skill I welcome you to the last
session in our two-day conference which
I think has been a great success I
wanted to remind everyone or perhaps
tell those of you who don't know that
there is there are two exhibits
downstairs on the ground floor one is
from buda-pesht from the 1956 institute
and is a series of photographs and on
another side of the fourth floor the
ground floor we have an exhibit from the
institute for national remembrance from
plus nine it's about june nineteen
fifty-six so all of the events that
we've been talking about for the last
couple of days and for those of you who
either couldn't see the film last night
freedoms fury which is being nominated
for an Oscar this year we hope or would
like to see it today professor Ivan
Sanders is going to show that film with
a commentary downstairs on a 12th floor
in room 12 19 just as soon as we finish
our session this afternoon and that
brings us to the the final really not a
panel but the concluding remarks by
Professor Robert Gervais and before I
handover the mic to him I thought I'd
talk a little bit about not the changes
in the world that were brought about by
the events of 1956 but about something
that really didn't change and for those
of you who are Hungarian and you will
forgive my corrupt pronunciation Lingle
magyar kept yo Bharat and in Polish
Pollock Vanguard vibrate on key this is
something that between the two countries
has been a kind of a model for a very
long time when in Poland people think
about Budapest in 1956 they sometimes
view it through the prism of the Warsaw
Uprising so those those visions those
images are quite close to them and that
accounts for the tremendous outpouring
of sympathy toward Hungarians in Poland
this year on the 50th anniversary of the
uprising on the twenty-third of October
the Hungarian ambassador in Warsaw
published a well a declaration really a
thank-you for poles for their support
and sympathy towards the uprising 50
years ago and it was published in the
major newspapers I translated it and
will paraphrase just a couple of
paragraphs for you to give an idea of
this very special relationship and the
ambassador said the poles through their
altruistic help & noble attitudes
created one of the most beautiful
chapters in two thousand year history of
Polish Hungarian friendship it is
impossible to reach everybody who gave
blood who collected money who
demonstrated in the streets informed
honor guards or tried to join the
fighting in buda-pesht it is impossible
to find all those who organized
transports to help fighting Budapest to
thank those who ignored the censorship
of the times and with undisguised
sympathy for the changes taking place
than in Hungary reported on those events
and to those who after the uprising was
put down Hank Hungarian flags on public
buildings and hosted the children of the
rebels as a sign of solidarity there
were those who publicly protested or hid
rebels who had fled hungry and there are
many who later made public and nurse the
memory of the uprising they all passed
the most important test the test of
human solidarity in recalling their
heroism and merit I want to remind
others of our thanks and at the same
time make the younger generation aware
of the timeless slogan for your freedom
and ours and that's the end of the
quotation the name of the ambassador of
the republic of hungary
oland is me hide your and this was done
just a few days ago so if international
politics changed as a result of the
events of 1956 at least the traditional
friendship that the poles and Hungarians
have traditionally enjoyed has not
changed it remains to see how that
friendship translates today into
cooperation within the visi grot group
the European Union NATO the United
Nations and other multilateral
organizations to set the events of 1956
into global context we've asked
professor Robert Jervis one of the
leading specialists on international
relations theory to offer some
concluding remarks Bob really doesn't
need much of an introduction but let me
just say that he's the Adlai Stevenson
professor of international politics and
the deputy chair of the political
science department here at Columbia
which according to one journal was
judged to be the best political science
department anywhere and i believe the
university also believes this because
they just opened up ten lines in the
political science department so they are
indeed a powerhouse professor Jervis is
working on a number of projects dealing
with among others the impact of the Cold
War on American and Soviet societies and
of course you know that he's been
listening quite intently to the
proceedings here over the last couple of
days so let me ask Bob to make some
concluding remarks thank you thank you
John I very much enjoyed and learned a
great deal from from the discussion but
before I start I FF say no we didn't get
tan lines up it's only actually three so
don't be too jealous my friends in
history and I know how I feel about
other departments oh I'm not but well
yeah I mean speakers often start by
saying how humble they are in the group
well it really is true here I I do
follow Cold War history as closely as I
can and
a teenager I do remember quite a bit
about the events of 56 and I actually
visited hungary poland and the soviet
union in the summer of nineteen sixty
one and can remember some the pockmarked
buildings of Budapest quite well and
something but if in the you know the
company this company you know my
knowledge of these events is is really
very very slight so what I'm going to do
and I will take in half an hour and no
more so the tournament time for
questions is at first I thought I was
going to talk about something a lot of
the questions that Charles Gotti had
raised in his very good opening talk
about illusions and the changes that 56
did and I think that's still interesting
and I you know maybe we'll come to it in
the question period but has this day
went on especially this morning's
session which I really thought was
extraordinarily interesting I decided
instead to make some general points
about ways of our understanding history
now I am NOT a historian but and but I
think there's so many interesting
questions about these event that these
questions bring up about what we think
about the way history works so let me do
that I have the last 11 topics which I
will skip over quickly let me read them
to you and then go back over them as
time permits some of them are obvious on
my hope or less obvious the first is
rough the most obvious that the tension
between generalization and dealing with
unique events related to that night
macro and micro second I think different
but not unrelated they are the
determinism vs contingency which I think
came up quite attention came up quite
strongly in this this morning third and
related to this is missed opportunities
and do you find opening early on events
narrowing down daz the possibilities
become
fewer I'm not sure that's a common way
of want to say a little about fourth do
we see a rationality and when we look at
decisions that are made can we talk
about rationality versus instinct vs
something I call motivated bias which is
some of you know like political
psychology may recognize which I want to
come to and I want answer it spawns
question I'm not sure i'll convince him
but i will answer it about why they were
so blind i think there is a generic
answer not surprisingly is related to
what i've been writing about recently so
a fifth question what how much are we
understanding this history through the
interaction of different countries
versus really internally generated
processes within each country related to
that can we locate dynamics of systems
at work and some of you know I wrote a
book on called system effects and I want
to talk a little about how these might
come into effect and then I want if I
have that leads the question of the
problems of actors keeping things in
control and the difference between
decisions and the way they're
implemented something Charles brought up
in his opening remarks and he and I
talked a good deal about afterwards and
i think is very important here then if i
have time i may skip the score but
question of elite mass relations in this
period and again explanations that focus
on one or the other and roll of nuclear
weapons which again some of you know i'm
very interested in and I think there's
some incoherent things that were said
the question is are we in coherent or
the decision makers incoherent I think
it's the latter but and then finally I
want to close by the question that can
came up this morning about how much to
current events legitimately influence
our understanding of the past it clearly
influences it but can we talk about a
way a legitimate versus illegitimate and
finally a little on some of the moral
question so I'm going to move quickly
through this list in a skin skip some
depending on how the
I'm goes right the first in some ways is
the most obvious general question
history and I'm not going to lecture
historians on it you know to what extent
can we generalize in history as
political science of course leans very
heavily on generalizations we as a sort
of discipline don't deny that they're
unique events but would deny you can
have a sensible explanation of unique
events because for political scientists
explanation means causation the only way
we can get a closed ation is comparison
his star especially comparisons even of
quite different cases historians I think
see the world differently it's no
accident some of us grew up to be a
political scientists even if we love
history and others historians I don't
think they'll of political science but
some of them read it and are interested
in it but yeah I think we do somehow
we've developed different ways of seeing
the world but even for historians I
think that the question of how much do
we understand the events of 1956 not
only in their historical time stream
which is very important for you but
comparisons for instance there wasn't
quite as much comparison between Hungary
and Poland as I had expected in our
discussion and there was some discussion
about how one influence the other which
I thought was quite interesting but can
we understand each of them better
through comparing them what about other
cases in in in the block especially
alternatives Romania right did loosen
the use the ties the Soviet Union it
didn't loosen its internal repression if
anything correctly grown quite the
opposite well were there some other
paths we can understand by looking at
other East European a third obviously is
their utility or what would be the
utility in comparing these two other
revolutions in different times and
places or even you might be 10 dentures
made looking at relations of countries
in what I'd say is the American sphere
of influence
especially countries in Latin America
does this does the American in overthrow
of the government in guate Guatemala the
intervention in dominican republic would
looking at these help us understand
things about hungry and potent political
science is out to say yes many of you i
think our apt to say no i'm agnostic but
i think that's a general question that
lurks behind some of this second
question which came up much more and
again i'm not going to only in one or
two am I going of answers no no no I'm
just gonna have questions the the second
is determinism vs contingency and I
think many of us go around and around in
our old own minds on this both as a
general orientation toward history and
in any specific events and we certainly
I think sought this morning on the
question of hungry what you know what
more Charlie what was determined and
when where were freedom of action where
when and how was freedom of action lost
clearly go back before the crew stuff
speech I think you're going to see lots
of possibilities arising if you could
imagine also Khrushchev wanting to D
Stalin eyes but doing it differently
could we then imagine not in a you know
a silly way but in a serious historical
way understanding the forces that are
ready to be unleashed in Poland and
Hungary can one imagine a third way
emerging emerging hungry turning out
more like Poland Poland turning out
different either more repression last
but on the one hand there it certain
things do look inevitable I mean it
certainly looks inevitable that no
country and East Europe can break loose
completely that is as as several people
said and I don't know if anyone in the
literature we disagree it it's hard to
imagine the Hungarian Revolution
succeeding in the sense of hungry
becoming neutral and becoming
communist now we can argue what else is
conceivable the outer looks
unconceivable on the other hand we know
and booze brought out very well in the
discussions about Hungary and Poland
that the Soviets a Khrushchev himself
and the and the Presidium vacillated in
both Hungary and Poland you know so is
it so crazy to imagine a whirl hung
Soviet Union intervening in Poland and
they're not intervening and hungry and
that leads to a very different world so
on the one hand you do get the sense of
determinism but they didn't seem to act
as though it's a determined world right
fruits Jeff stays up all night on this
and then well is there something odd
about saying it is determined even
though the people who made the decisions
think they have freedom of choice I mean
this is a broad philosophical question
you people have cysts Orient's I think
I've wrestled with it more than I but
you know you we have this discrepancy
there's a phrase that's a number of us
another way to get at this is to say yes
there seemed to be events that look to
be crucial perhaps the shooting of the
the Hungarian secret police and that
we've talked about although we don't
know what what the impression was but
let me take the argument that yes that
was crucial well you could say that was
in some sense an accident in that you
know if there hadn't been photographs or
things had gone different at that day
the information wouldn't have gotten two
crews job when it did that's true but
then we have to ask what like what
events were quite likely that would have
been functional substitutes because I
think a determinist is going to say even
if that hadn't happened the momentum of
the revolution was such that it was
going to produce incidents like that in
one of in Vietnam me as many of you know
the American bombing of North Vietnam
and early 65 was triggered not work by
the attack
ACK on the American air base at play KU
bundy was who I think was expose
whatever you think of the policies i
think bundy i met he was a friend of
mine was extraordinarily thoughtful at
least in retrospect and he was later
asked about was that crucial and he said
play coos are like streetcars and what
that means is if your way if you wait
long enough one will come along it'll
take you where you want to go not that
we trumped-up play coup but that if
pleco hadn't happened other things would
have it would have taken to the same
destination it's an interesting
statement but you know Mac was there in
Vietnam when clay who happened and he
would take me we went to the scene and
he saw dead bodies which was not youth
usual and he wrote when he finished he
wrote a cable very different than you
written before where play was play cool
like a street car anyway alright the
next point is closely related so I will
be quicker on it were there missed
opportunities were there real
possibilities for events turning out
differently where they're turning points
or turning points with it did and didn't
turn the classic case of course the 1848
revolutions in East and Europe about
were these turning points and which
countries turned in which didn't anyway
um when this relates to the way we write
history both macro and micro when we
look at the very minute by minute or
hour by hour it's inherently fascinating
and i just love history of that kind but
the question obviously is in a sense
does it matter were there when we do it
that way i think we often imply there
were missed opportunities things that
could have gone differently usually
could have gone better now I
psychologically we like to think that on
the other hand logically the other
branch seems to me at least as possible
that is missed opportunities in the bed
the things that could have gone much
much worse
and but we don't like to think about
those as much some of you said I'm sorry
there were too many people in too many
names but something after October 23rd
there were no missed opportunities the
trains that we had left the station well
you know I think in this group that
you're going to argue about that but I
think we do tend to think of
possibilities narrowing as we go on but
there's a danger there because in
certain ways new possibilities may open
up and that's very hard to you know get
a hold of but that's part of that missed
opportunity the fourth point which is of
quite those three I think go together in
generalizations that determinism and
missed opportunities I think our length
that the next point is not when we look
at this history and try to understand
events through decisions that were made
which is by no means the only way to do
it but since my own work is on some of
its on perceptions and decision making
it the way I find congenial and and
useful I think without doing terrible
injustice we can see some explanation
sort of form general rationality I mean
rest on Possible's of rationality
especially in political science a second
looks more partly at irrationality but
partly what I think can be labeled
instinct and then there's a third
category of what I call motivated bias
which I want to talk about but let me
just mention the other two first that
our first impulse I think and rightly so
is to do a rational explanation not in a
fancy sense of rationality that
political signs it's an economist do but
in the more common sense what was the
goal of a particular actor it's the
political science jargon you for person
group whatever we're looking at what was
the what were the goals of the actor and
how then did the actor Rhys
what means ends chains and beliefs were
in the mind that led to that you know
why when we say well I did she do that I
think that's what we're asking what did
you want to achieve how did she see the
world to make that happen and why did
she think that certain actions were
likely to reach those goals that isn't
the only way however I think a lot of
decisions are not calculated I believe
in there are some psychologists and
political scientists who have argued
this with more detail than and I have a
lot of very important decisions are
instinctive and I don't know these are
some arguments that these will
systematically by the way be superior to
the calculated ones but I think there
are a number of important decisions that
that do seem to be instinctive let me
give you an example not from this but
the Berlin Blockade the the day as you
know it sort of not a doesn't announce a
particular time but still the crucial
meeting after it's clear that Berlin is
being blockaded Truman's advisors are
around before the president
comes in then it's clear that you know
they're ready to talk about how the US
extra kate's itself Truman walks in the
room and says we're staying in Berlin
now we're talking about how we're going
to you know how we're going to pull this
off you know Truman this is not like
Truman Truman's not decisive usually
many of the superficial biographies
claim he is because Truman wants to
pretend he's decisive because in fact
he's very indecisive what happened we
don't know it doesn't look like actress
and got to and that's a normal thing
it's his instinct I think he feels in
his gut we have to stay and we're going
to figure out how to do it it's hard for
us to analyze now I think the third
process at work is what I call barring
from from psychologists motivated biases
up so to think of wishful thinking which
I think I don't like the term because it
misses on but that's the sort of the
broad idea well more specifically the
idea is that when people are in very
difficult positions and they face
without trade-offs between deeply held
values they will not usually face those
trade off those choices explicitly
instead they will come to believe that
they don't have to sacrifice deeply held
values they will not face the world as
it is for its fans question how could
they be so blind well you have
Khrushchev had to be blind he could not
recognize the degree to which the Soviet
Union was hated in Hungary and keep his
other core values how could a person who
is a dedicated communist and Bill isn't
here to how but you know that's what he
says in the biography I think that's
what most people say he believed in
community believed that it would be
effective that it was best how can you
so you believe that in Allah and you
believe in your country in your country
doing good and you also believe that
this country that you have liberated and
are leading on the path to prosperity
justly that almost everyone hates you
you can't keep those things in your mind
without terrible psychological pain how
could I zan howre believe on the one
hand that yes we could hold out the hope
for rollback which he had to believe
partly for domestic politics we could
keep the hope alive and in fact maybe it
would work because you know still high
fear of nuclear war then I fear we
wouldn't survive the coming arms race
incoming Soviet you know nuclear parity
so how could he believed he believes
that he also clearly believes that the
Soviets can crush any rebellion in
Eastern Europe and that the u.s. can't
come to the assistance of these
countries because we just don't have the
whole forces on the ground to do so I
don't think it
surely I don't think it would led to a
nuclear war and I'm skeptical that
Eisenhower believe that but i'm not sure
but anyway we couldn't have done it we
don't our army that's not big enough
well how can he believe you know why
does he not why don't they plan ahead
why don't they think about these inks
that they do they realize they're in an
intolerable political and psychological
position when I had a whispered
conversation with my colleague Bob leg
vole who can't be here this afternoon
and Bob Simon accused me of reading back
into history my view of the Bush
administration no there are parallels
but I I've worked on this explanation
long before Iraq and I have a an
enormous load of historical examples
that fit this equation doesn't mean it's
right but no it's not just so I think
you find people believing being blind in
this way and it is very common that's it
the same way that Roosevelt believed you
could have soft spheres of influence in
Eastern Europe which is and i believe
was that the word impossibility he
didn't believe that he would have had to
face an intolerable choice intolerable
politically intolerable psychologically
how could the hungarians believe they
could throw the Soviets out or believe
that the u.s. you know would come to
their assistance well partly their
information on the ladder was sharply
limited but what else are they to
believe so I think this idea of how
people think is very important here
related to this is how hard it is to
reconstruct these decisions yeah it is
true in 10 what we've seen that it's the
fascinating discussion about what the
Malon notes can and can't tell us and we
can have counterpart discussions in the
US as you know the NSC documents on
eisenhower period are incredibly rich I
mean they're almost verbatim marvelous
discussion down to the fact that it will
say when Eisenhower gets annoyed quite
frequently it will say there's the
president replied with some
one and so you get all that it's
marvelous but we know Eisenhower's not
using the NSC to make decisions he's
using it to bounce ideas to get the
people in the NSC to see each other's
views they can operate to inform himself
but he's not making decisions there
those are in the back room well thanks
to Andy good pastor we have some of that
but there's an awful lot we don't have
and we were told here that clearly when
crew stuff comes in saying I've reversed
the decision there's some backroom
things we don't have so we know we have
enormous limits here to answering these
questions but I want to flag the
psychological problem which is worse
there's a marvelous article in
Psychology called telling more than we
can know to make a long story short we
that is the the cognitive and social
psychologists have I think overwhelming
evidence that really fits with a more
partly ego dynamic view of unconscious
not taking all of the Freudian audience
the basic point is that most of our
mental processing is unconscious the
enormous variety enormous all the visual
processing you're doing you know all
sorts of stuff is you know you're not
aware of what you're doing it's you know
the enormous bulk 90 something percent
if we're is unconscious okay you say
well that's true of these routine things
here but it's much more than that we
know through experiments I don't I won't
want to go into them they don't of the
time but you can run experiments and
then you ask people what made you reach
this impression or decision and they
will tell you and there are no
incentives for them to lie to you but we
know because of the experimental
manipulations we've done that people are
that it isn't right other things that
they don't realize influence them have
influenced them and we really do I think
know that now does that prove this is
the limits of these people know it isn't
you know that this context is different
these are much more considered judgments
I believe though it is true I believe
that are even if we could bring the
decision-makers back to life or BF leo
interview them as they're making the
decision they could not they could tell
us something you know they have to tell
something they wouldn't tell us what but
we couldn't be sure what they're telling
us is the truth not because they're
trying to lie to us but because a lot of
these feelings at all linked to instinct
gut feelings they you know the answers
they're giving of the rationalizations
they're not the factors that are most
deeply moving them and this is a problem
all right I'm going to skip over several
things obviously let me just see what I
do on a skip can you skip the one on
interaction a little but I do want to
get a related thing briefly on dynamics
of systems because I say written about
things like this in my book system
effects in which I I do think is a book
that actually has closer ties historians
and other things it's somewhat it's
similar those you know John goddesses
landscape of history my arguments and
John's are developed independently but
have quite a bit of parallel so they're
both based on various arguments from
biology and complexity theory anyway the
basic argument is much of history and
social life is a system not in any fancy
way but just in the way there are a lot
of interconnections and it means that
you get complicated feedbacks in the
sense of positive of self reinforcing
and self dampening processes we get a
lot of nonlinearities that is big jumps
and the timing is often very important
and related to this and this came out a
lot in yesterday's discussion a
prevalence of unintended consequences
because systems are complicated enough
so that even later observers but
certainly contemporary decision-makers
can't foresee the consequences of what
they'll do there is you know we talked
about the fog of war but there's the fog
of peace I mean the idea that with
obvious crucified no yep true stuff
speech to the extent it was important
leading up to these events I think the
consensus that I heard and read is that
it is obviously he didn't know in some
ways he he couldn't know psychologically
for reasons I've said but I'm not even
sure if even you put that aside that one
could ask a reasonable person to know
that though the possibilities are so
great the interconnections are so
complicated that you couldn't tell so we
have a great many things here that are
the the events are the x-plane buys the
unintended consequences of actions taken
for quite different purposes and I think
this doesn't mean in any way I think
that history is meaningless or that we
can't understand it it does first give
us I hope great sympathy for
decision-makers in the sense of when
they turned out wrong it's not
surprising it does though mean that we
should expect them to be surprised often
along those lines that what's crucial in
this case made is the question of
control stability and stability I mean I
think we heard that especially yesterday
all I came up somewhat this morning that
for the Soviet Union what was crucial is
event until in East Europe could be kept
in control their boundaries I think that
they were willing to tolerate were large
if they were predictable if you knew how
far they would go yo the Hungarians of
poles would go and stop I think quite a
few things were tolerable but of course
that often simply is not the case the
Polish leaders and Hungarian leaders I
think could not say we will go this far
and no further because the second
obsessing revolutions or you are you
have diabetes dynamics that are
unforeseen almost by definition if you
could foresee them they wouldn't be a
revolution and that none of the leaders
could tell where this was going whether
say if Nagy had been a different person
he could have controlled events more or
when he could about you know I'm it's in
every question I mavi out of that game
but even for that what would happen two
year later or two years later clearly
what a lot of what's motivating people
are not the worries for the immediate
future but two three steps down the road
the set of unintended consequences that
could occur and then what's very
important is their views about what's
likely and their views about what
arrangements are stable and what view
and what arrangements are unstable you
know that is you could put something in
place perhaps in Hungary but would it
stay in place I think we see that
stability and control coming through
related somewhat in fact that decision
makers don't control the way decisions
were implemented this comes up i think a
lot on the rfe questions what was
decided in Washington what Washington
knew and Charles stresses partly ins
talk and we were talking about it the
degree to which things happen on the
ground
that the decision-makers didn't know
about didn't want every case I've looked
at in you know you just find that right
i mean you find decision-makers not only
not understanding what the other side is
doing they don't understand what their
side is doing leaving aside a
revolutionary situation that decisions
get implemented through long chains and
even when you have people trying to do
what they're supposed to do things end
up in a very very different way and some
decision-makers more aware than others
but it's a really complicating factor
that plays partly into control and
stability all right I've overrun so I'm
skipping another cop without including
nuclear weapons which are near and dear
to my heart I've written two books on
them but i do want to take about three
minutes more in four minutes more and
and raise to other topics that i think
came out this morning and absolutely
fascinating are no privileged position
on either of them i haven't written on
them but i think they're fascinating one
goes see me do a lot of the way we think
about history there was one of the
speakers this morning talked about how
far back do we go to understand hungry
and 56 and it's fan picked up on that
but also in that discussion both what he
said and what his van said there's the
other way that is what about events that
came later now obviously we can't use
those to explain what went before right
that you know unless you're going to get
into some rather odd ideas we can play
quantum physics and running things
backward but we're not going to do that
okay but do events that come later shed
light on what happened before well first
of all they do affect our
interpretations is just no doubt that
our present in facts the way we read the
past but we will then try to avoid that
but is there a legitimate way and it may
and we were talking about this over
lunch and it came out also in the
discussion this morning to the extent
that one looks at hungry now and were
is a lot about the country being dis
unified worried about extreme right-wing
groups well then not obviously I don't
think change is sort of the clauses of
the Hungarian Revolution but it does
perhaps raise the question of what would
have happened had the Soviets not
intervene that is would you have had a
happy ending so does be happy from just
you know standpoint of fires whom were
fairly shared liberal in the broad sense
values that uh what has happened later
perhaps does legitimately reveal things
about that the political forces in the
country the political dynamics that do
are relevant to missed opportunities or
where things would have gone but this is
sort of a strange world now we're
talking about it about how we add in
what's happening now certainly the way
we look at the Hungarian and polish
revolutions is very different after
nineteen eighty nine and one of the
pamphlets I put picked up outside as
documents and the one the last section
is headed victory in defeat what you
couldn't have written we couldn't
written this of course before 89 but you
wouldn't have had that and the way we
see it is I think in those terms is
because of what has happened and how it
to what extent does this help us
understand 56 into what a sentence
distort it finally what about the role
of moral judgments again in
understanding the events yesterday one
of the speakers I think took exception
to what built aldman until maybe it was
only this had said about Khrushchev sort
of starting out as a really good person
and I think our evaluation or some of
our sense of the events is partly the
party we're driven to them because we
are we do find deep moral concerns in
these certainly the future of the
country after
yes fan of course knows much more about
this written marvelously about it in
terms of collaborators and resistors and
the judgments that are made and the
shifting sands on this clearly we do
without I hope being too oversimplified
we are making moral judgments about the
way people behaved which are partly
linked to the empirical question of were
there missed opportunities partly linked
to the questions of you know what are
our responsibilities but I think the
question of I saw my worry when I read
especially Cold War history didn't see
it coming out in this mean but a lot of
standard Cold War history I think is
very how's it contaminated by people's
current political views in the way there
awarding gold stars to some decision
makers and you know negative ones to
others and I I don't think that's a
useful way to understand most history on
the other hand I think in some of these
events the moral judgments and the
questions of why people acted as they
could and what possibilities there were
are intertwined and I think there is
both a great danger that we will both
let for his judgments of why things
happened lead to moral judgments that
are inappropriate and there's a danger
of reading it the other way around that
is also having strong moral views that
then lead us to not understanding the
history of the time on the other hand I
think we've somehow do have to keep
these to the understanding and our moral
judgments of them we do have to keep
those going together in a creative way
although I'm not sure how one does that
thank you and thank you for the
indulgence of the extra five minute
funk about open up the floor to
questions comments please identify
yourself
three months ago
on a faculty knows there was a lecturer
or deprecating community I went to live
the person was either enormously stupid
what a lonesome
I still up just like now and I said two
man gentlemen classless society is
idiotic a hundred and sixty IP / 785 a
person cannot be in the same class the
reason why did I tell you why I'm going
to this the reason why Lenin and Marx
had invented communism is because they
went the stupidest and the laziest
segment of society and give them power
therefore they do anything that would
ask
this is what happened upon from full
hundred something on and the partners
convey the country and this point has a
population all the way through the 3rd
50 years the variance in Hungary are
allowed to minorities huge numbers of
Germans entered and Spaniards there
because popular and what people consider
is in nineteen fifties
what wasn't company was so unthinkable
so horrendous totalitarian that there
are no words to explain I tell you story
after story a friend of ours in high
school
disappear the director of the hospital
pull the parasitic what happened he said
he meant to the American Embassy for
cultural to watch the secret police
surrounded the area they picked him up
at the movies they beat him and we have
to sleep on floor because
I custodian story
and what happens now
the Hungarians who are called by
Hungarians are the merit and the others
who collected the current social with
government who is a communist government
Prime Minister of kroger it is a
communist furthermore but wait we're
talking about 1956 so let's let's stay
on track if you have a question please
ask today a communist government isn't
full refund
who have number one lie was required
seven dollars he lie he didn't do that
the government didn't do what they said
they would do they said they were lower
taxes the way to taxes etc can hide in
every civilized country they would have
redesigned accepted hundred they lie
they crossed there oh I have requested
the best on the order I'm sorry so the
point is that 1956 56 is not over it's
still going on to this day I think
that's become abundantly clear during
the course of the last two days yeah
static
so long
Oh
let's let's gather a few questions
before we return mark is very much into
a good on its vow one quick point
another question which out that it's
question about decision makers of not
knowing what
this I think was well summed up by JFK
during the Cuban Missile Crisis and
talking about Major Anderson t2 but the
other one
said some is always some son of a bitch
but the question is are the pointy
raised about the impact of current
events or subsequent events on our
perceptions of events prior to that I
always tend to be averse
not to say that that you can understand
the subsequent events a lot better than
what we have that but I think to go back
say at looking at 56 knowing what
happened to me sometimes the screw it
quite significantly here understand and
50 60 I try to resist that myself I
think by and large you do do but I'd
like that you say to worry about that
perfect Christian
all right money you know although some
of these questions are ones in which
there you know I think others could
comment as well as I could I don't even
get each other with a lot about hungry
now which I know nothing about except I
think it does raise to questions will
one related to marks but point but it
does raise another which is when you
find how do we explain behavior and
sometimes it seems inexplicable that is
people believe things that just seem so
morally repugnant or that seem so
foolish and yet people did believe them
obviously did act on them and some of
that we can say oh you know they were
doing it it was their own self-interest
friends we can talk we could argue that
certain say cumulative disease or any
leaders were just lining their own
pockets and they didn't believe things
they were saying I don't think I think
that may be true of some people at some
time but I think in fact that's often
not true and I think it's a general
problem and you people say his
historians will wrestle with it much
more to try to explain things that seem
so weird or again morally repugnant
discussions is now how we explain that
most people in the Western world
believed in slavery believed it was
appropriate of any belief that was moral
and how do you explain that without them
it's all I've seen emo early complicit
again I read too many books that that
when they take away my target a
marvelous book on London in 1900 it was
very evocative and but every 10 pages
the guy had to stop and say and the
workers were terribly
Dennis was evil or the dockworkers you
know were brought in from the Empire and
they were treated off me or oh the web
they thought about women you know give
me a drink that this apart this is not
the way to understand what I want to
know is how did that society function
and how did people believe in how we
think are self-evidently wrong it sure
as hell 50 years or hundred years are
people going to be sitting around and
then into the title explain how we
thought certain things that they know or
morally wrong so I don't want to be
superior to them I want to understand
how they you know not only their
you-know-whats them but the social
background what are the dynamics
personal that sustained believes that to
us make them either knaves or fools I
think that's a terribly hard project and
I just want to under on how hard it is
and it's one that say my discipline
doesn't engage in and which may be to be
unfair I read too much history that I
think doesn't engage in it and I think
it's part of our tasks part of it I
would come back maybe I'm now in the law
of the instrument I explained everything
the same way it's very hard if we look
at slave owners and say they're very
some of them are very reasonable people
actually in our Terms and they're very
thoughtful this makes us very
uncomfortable that video we're going to
be driven in places that we don't want
to be on the question of again many of
you know this more whoa was it a mistake
for the Soviet Union to do what they did
to East Europe my sense here is the
inevitability in two ways yes in some
ways it was a mistake but it was not
know avoid it was not avoidable first I
think and mark I don't know our other
top 10 tips talent and others lost out
more cynical than Khrushchev had an
element of truth believers how
you were bringing something that was
good to these countries but more
important of course you needed them as a
glacis for security reasons and what I
think FDR never said but me and many
people believed what you could get was I
forgot who's raised it is but soft
spheres of influence that the Soviet
Union would establish in Eastern Europe
regimes that were sorta like Finland I
mean they were friendly forced to be
friendly but yeah but they could control
their own populations they would be
neutrally eternity not mad as the Soviet
Union but they would there wouldn't be
tight control but that I think is
unstable that that world was impossible
given the dynamics on the ground so
here's another case where if you will
Stalin and FDR the Stalin and Truman
could agree that's great but it doesn't
if given the local dynamics it could not
it couldn't happen and this relates art
mark went yes ma I do think my gentle
bias is the same as yours and but I
think there is a legitimate way of
looking back to see what's possible like
I think the analysis i gave which is
obviously very debatable and sheds light
not up on why they did it but does make
you see it differently it does so anyway
say this was inevitable and I think
that's then if the reason is my
illegitimate historical judgment if you
say that given the nature of revolutions
this family saying given the nature of
Hungarian society at the time that had
the Soviets not intervened we wouldn't
have
what sort of liberals again from broadly
would have liked a pluralist democracy
tolerant etc that that was not possible
and the reason I can argue that I'm very
limited evidence i mean is because of
what happened later i think that form of
argument may be legitimate but I agree
it's generally have a problem just
briefly on the nuclear weapons and you
look at him more than I have a dread the
NSC some of them but not all we have the
bizarre situation that the Soviet
nuclear capabilities recently the US and
56 are very limited now my colleague
dick Bev's another for Trent like more
track and bird knows better than I but
I'm pretty sure maybe gets one way
suicide missions I don't know if the
Soviets even practiced that I mean it
was it'd be very hard for the Soviets to
deliver nuclear weapons to the
continental United States on the other
hand American decision makers are don't
have that confidence partly it's easy to
look back and say all they couldn't've
done before debating the decision could
lead to even a small number of nuclear
weapons landing on the US you know you
have to take a different stance but
still that I find it puzzling that in 56
and even we could Cuba Missile Crisis
alright differently American decision
makers are acting as though there is
local nuclear parody when they're just
clearly is mom and I don't fully
understand that so I am torn in my sense
of what influence nuclear weapons were
having here it may be something that
they're influencing people even though a
purely rational argument would say that
they wouldn't i'd like to see the
records more carefully read them than I
have and see also what backup
briefings if there were they were
getting on what the balance was it also
is truth about this time they were
producing papers about where the balance
was going which of course was the Soviet
force was growing and it could be that
in their minds decision makers read into
where they were where things were going
on the other hand and I think you know
this Beth loves I have a lot of stuff
there was a big debate in the u.s. from
the late 40s still percolating out a
little but ending after 56 on should we
have a preventive war because the
American advance the clear advantage was
eroding and I think partly when
Eisenhower and others say well we can't
do anything because of the danger of
nuclear war my sense of what they're
doing is trying to put the final at
stake through the heart of the argument
of preventive war that they're really
not thinking that there's a real danger
nuclear war here but they're wanting to
make clear that that debate is over once
and for all but i'm not on firm ground
in my conclusion on that and you say you
and others may know more hold on
professor deck professor proton user and
on video earlier mention of
which father once behavior his readers
and isn't you look at the
revolutionaries of diseases most banal
body and the film that i'm not watching
his home and that book way to the big
successes were torn from the plan sure
that in the news or other people who
went through very complicated process
some of them saying he his film i
started out as a communist and peasant
boy grow up in poverty and then the
party of the embassy and style died i
tried seriously i love it others say I
was a communist I mean the Communists I
was preceded by the Communist tonight by
the NDA for company again allah says I
grew up in a world first person but what
is revealing systole is a transformation
of people or persons and that brings me
back to my earlier study of preparation
this some exceptions in Europe most of
the collaborators become and it mostly
collaborators who tend to become
resistors and there are some exceptions
that Poland people they were practically
no possibility for correlation but
otherwise in the normal course of events
were accordingly people eating and in
there actually a life worthy is to be in
France in 1940 because I'm a threat and
one has to collaborate as he went
silently 44
presonus opportunism or in the kangaroo
team we have to consider the 56
travelers of us who revered
intellectually that from these
possibilities practically live our
conceptions the 33 circular or Congress
party members of parliament the film
that we worked yesterday rotatory as one
of the intellectual resistors he'd
probably was not a party and very cool
he wasn't at his August exception was
the road
but even be seized by the surprise
Manila notably those to deter fighting
were very often bonus part images I
think there are statistics one of the
four or something right there are
several events when the rosters said to
the fighters widened writers and Nuala
professions and ND that about the
Communist Party membership there were
certain receptors that physical effects
on your who last survivor of Auschwitz F
over this part number s102 that point
as a person field so to this point
you were
get up I
I
only
I've kind of just one comment I want to
make I did these quest I mean part of I
got out of the topic party from both
reading what his fans written over the
years which I find just enormously
stimulating him and the discussion would
comment and instruction over lunch and
uh I think perhaps Americans are finding
these discussions particularly difficult
because we have not lived through
difficult times that is you know that
the United States certainly in my
lifetime you know if we've all made
moral choices who should we've gone down
or we breathe enough I wasn't to go down
the South you know when the for the
civil rights movement when it was
dangerous you know we've all changed
many of us change the fuse on so the
ideas related to feminist arguments but
you know but basically the US for Athena
a remarkably calm era where you don't
find as may you find people changing
their political views but the
transformation is a very good word that
its many uses I think something that
Americans don't find and so American
academical can learn it you know through
history but partly you learn it from
living it if not you your parent and I
wonder if the American understanding of
history and sensitivities of the moral
question is just not all not only
overturn until not as subtle on here and
maybe also the other side of the coin
that wiling mark shares this feeling it
that the Cold War history I read that I
find so moralizing doesn't do the sorts
of questions is Valis do it you know it
does you know if you were black hats and
white hats and I wonder if American
historians tend to do that is that the
other side of the deformation that they
either ignore the
questions or do it in a way that is not
as as helpful again reflecting they
threw a much easier life that we all
have had this problem of how our present
attitudes and our present existence at
this time colors are our justice event
and as somebody deals with literature I
mean this is a this is a preventive
dilemma because I mean there are people
who take the genre of the historical
novel say I mean though this is a this
is this is about this strong row because
there's no service or for anybody who
writes it and it is impossible to put
yourself in a different time without hey
that's too many it is possible to argue
that for this you know to remind
historians that it made that in years is
a long enough time so for anybody to
himself and to his previous self how you
fought about
ago perhaps is not possible because
there are so many other things that we
have forgotten about that but at the
same time asked a literate person i also
have to remind myself that that we can
still read and enjoy things that would
it not to gears a little bit but about
years ago which indicates that there are
there are constants otherwise those
works would be unintelligible to us and
on enjoyable so I mean I just you maybe
think again about these questions there
are some relatives here to this point to
Professor dax point no professor proton
we're very good at trying to
conceptualize all the things that happen
going on yeah I wanted to come back to
the decision
I was actually surprised enough to ask
you to elaborate a little bit natural
sort of emphasize also green sticks in
decision making and I was surprised
because it seemed to me Robert by
logistic approach because well if you
believe in the death instinct of the
creative instincts okay but i thought
you know that when decision makers are
coming in behind the decision they made
first of all they do have prior
information you mentioned proven i would
want to check this but i think there was
a telegram or a memo from playing with
sitting in Berlin just before his grew
up where he said if the linen is lost
Germany will be not Europe will be multi
unjust you know really why we have to do
something so here you get the sort of
but more open and more broadly it seems
to be that decision making is not by
logistically retirement but also a beach
and I would want to look at the context
in which this
in this case of American and another
piece on
so is actually operating and what could
quit suffered a second question we just
buried a gift at the very end I've been
very much involved but of thinking about
conference I don't want to give another
lecture but it would be wonderful if
beyond the conceptualization that I very
illuminating you put tell us what you
think is the larger international
significance of these events
study for two days because there is of
course
yep let me take them back I realize I
instinct this is is although some people
who work in this vein who I'm drawing on
use the term instinct I it may be the
misleading word because i don't mean
instinct in the sort of group biological
way as you said the drive for food or
sex or young survival i don't mean that
a medal so I admit the Berlin I'm going
on my memory of that an article by
deadline or friend and former colleague
Debbie Larson I haven't reread it and
you may well be right but what I do mean
is almost say you know it's biological
but different gut feeling that is yes it
isn't as though they aren't thinking and
calculating at all but something they
don't understand fully leads that
conclusion even and I don't mean any we
want to exclude the cultural element or
or in personality but rather than Truman
sitting down with a you know a yellow
pad and doing what Nixon said he did
which I don't believe he ever did you
know list all the pros and all the comms
and here are four ways in which this
could do no its you know he may get some
information but he reaches with call
closure very very quickly we're going to
do this when we it's crazy how the hell
can you decide to stay in Berlin without
knowing that it's possible and as I
think the experts will agree that given
the American thinking at the time it
wasn't possible I mean you know the
improvisation worked but no one none of
the people who knew the logistics
believed that it could have worked and
internal soviet acquiesced i mean they
could have done
lot of other stuff that made this entry
difficult so when I say instinctive it I
I mean it in were that way I should
check to see you meme and the clay cable
would be quite quite interesting but
more my senses and here on even thinner
grounds it Truman was getting fed up and
my reading of Truman is you know he is a
quite emotional distant and that he just
had had and was going to do you know he
wasn't going to then calculate he was
just going to take a strong position are
you on your second point let me to say a
little not much I I sort of initially
was going to do that but I found by the
this morning's discussion so fast man
bring up the other 1956 is a turning
point and for better and for worse I've
anything it does end a lot of illusions
on both sides soon the Soviets realized
well they're not going to be loved you
know that they have a perennial problem
they have to manage in a way that I'm
not sure they realized before I again
I'd leave it you people know this up
much more also i think it's the final
again blown to any hopes of making real
progress in west europe the desertion of
the intellectuals I think kills and
there wasn't a lot of hope but I think
there was some hope before that their
system was going to have that appeal
it's a for the Soviets again I think
related to the final realization of
dividing Germany and Europe I think it
to on the American side that there are
things that and I all about the West
Europeans at all the Americans of course
have rejected neutralization of Germany
for very good reasons
I would defend that and but anyway they
have rejected it but so there still is a
some popularity that there's some hope
for neutralization of East Europe if not
of West Europe roll back is a little
more than rhetoric not a lot but the
discussion preventive war has pretty
much died down but I'm not sure it's
completely dead there's the fear that's
very strong in the late 40s and early
50s that the u.s. cannot stand a long
cold war and one of the someone
mentioned petrovich's book is published
in series aiko evident and I think it's
a marvelous book and some the great
works out that I was really amazed by
and I think maybe people disagree
Aventine a rebuttal but in the late 40s
up to I think about 50 a lot of people
in the US simply don't think you can
have a long cold war they they either
lead to war through various accidents or
the American Society will in some ways
crumble or insist on lashing out so one
of the reason you get quite heavy covert
action unsuccessful quite heavy in late
40s and through Eisenhower is the belief
that war is inevitable unless we end
this I think that someone coming through
these crises and Suez perhaps they were
there's an understanding turns out to be
true but a belief that the system is
manageable that we can have a long cold
war and survive as a social system we're
not going to really get into war that
getting the year of nuclear parity isn't
going to be pleasant but it's survivable
so I think in a way it does make the
world much more stable or not as a
pleasant stability but I think it does
it
it really is an end of an era from if
you were the beginning of the Cold War I
was changing but i think it is in that
sense if not a turning point if you get
those closed doors it does solidify
people's minds beliefs and ideas that
were forming and make it you're fully
accepted and i think that is extremely
important and I think it partly helps
explain it lead to part of the next
phase to be over schematic of the
competition in the third world because
if Europe is stable for variety of both
sides turn to the third world so it's in
some ways the end of the cold war on you
at the end of the Cold War Europe for
the people there but I think it's always
it is if you were to write a book you
could fit until 56 you have to write
about Europe you could write in some
ways a lot about the Cold War after 56
without Europe Oslo did you up to this
point then in that case let me ask this
gentleman has been patiently waiting
experience mr. Borden
and the legend was officially the
promise are the pillars I'm sorry the
miners are pivotal that's what you
ordered I spent one year for my day he
comments more than anybody else I know
what to delete this I have cell suicide
with pain but they did
yes and after one year into the
community these are the pillars of the
Communist Party or you have two jerseys
and fires go to the less and that's a
veteran 56 and that's a loofah Soviet
Union or you have to do just need before
there was no large support or any okay
suppressive and buy it and others and
the second is my opinion my opinion is
that both issues in bexley left what
they seem like a fool of yes we are
looking for the market and the Politburo
that on here in the end from this social
responsibility for their they had their
own stores they would buy matter
cigarettes in 1953 and nineteen seventy
sixty five and they
and that was probably close to ninety
percent of the
operation that any moment there was
nothing a force to suppress them
thank you Mr Sarkozy Carol tonga I'm
story five very curious that what
persons name it seems not to mention i
haven't been here in the morning
and that is the Corporal from brown and
he was just bed for 11 years but what do
you think about it and this is the
typical I had something that will be
arguing the German Communist communities
late 50s and 60s about the contribution
of the Soviets
secret would indeed Natasha bring over
hip
and you know even compare evils but
there's no question hip or fascism 50
million people almost incredible evils
in history and the Soviets did
contribute very much take that away from
and I've always had trouble when they
mentioned their 20 million dead you know
and there that I argued that Lisa they'd
and argued tank instruction behind the
Urals 3,000 packs of three thousand
German tanks of course so is there any
kind of moral high on the part of the
Soviets in this whole picture that we're
talking just 11 years African
I should thankful demise what I just
want one small with it I mean I assume
when you but that the Soviets did have
it was the sense of entitlement in wet
eastern your you know that they did her
earn it certainly all the exploitation
and and more than that professor board
why was there that point eight
completely illogical solution dependable
middleboro stylist position behind that
deliver the solution but when they make
decision environments for cleaned up and
I went over the outside world and this
is the public servant politician
unless you understand me to go ridin is
formulated and let me give you a couple
of examples pushto says that events in
Poland no more than the summer calendar
in 20 minutes North have watchmen he
wants to like a bona fide what's the
lifestyle is for me the most younger for
the future CBS in full separately and
thousand a look the important to Gary
the disaster he's got the solution you
should appoint me a lot because his role
in person who competitive situation
hungry and what song about response
washes you through the Communist can be
attributed to the dread it will write
his views and in the summer of different
six he said there's a lot of post out
propaganda hunger Tito s and inferior
race at par 70 for the objective
situation political and economic
situation is sounding hundred there
basically
the day the interpretive the outside
border if you really push her memoirs it
becomes every clear that it absolutely
incapable of comprehending what who are
you are outside of his mental world
marketing management this is pretty
crucial in understanding the role of
liability and so as did not occupy this
alert but it is devoted to be
seven-eighths one mentioned before the
grand or the bureau design the attorney
economic and political but this is your
party the way they understood the
behavior of the nest and the way they
understood their own the hip rotation in
this understand wish to the previously
to the victory of passion coolio to the
back
you know one of the good things I think
about these crises in some of the
evidence of the word about hope what was
going on the countries themselves as
well
you know it with different views now
that people people's perceptions
misperception misperceptions and
ways of approaching particular threats
and price he differ and the word debate
stockings matters but but that that as
decisions were being formed something it
fits a lot of what we wrote it worked on
this perception perceptions of
misperceptions and some that people as
as the range of possibilities is
narrowing people focus in a lot of these
differences in use in the gift shop
any other questions
in 1947
honest
awesome
it might be
army before I webinar in high school I
noticed that
John you want to be anywhere happy
so in totalitarian regime that forced
people even if they hated it
and last thing is that most Americans
don't know that became great impression
last time anybody else would ya
is usual
and
good
essentially
the
thank you
we would be
be
Peter pastor family did not start you
already wanted a sea of importance but
he made a bailable Hitler and certainly
because not very happy to offer the
Balkans
so sorry
conversations
conversation
the first things that visit the private
sector
deal with
so when the contrast said with
discretion of ideological justification
because after the will receive that for
this territory the ideological
justification is that from the next war
okay we're going to pass on answering
that question I think I think it remains
for me just to conclude the conference
I'd like to remind everybody that our
presence here is thanks a lot of people
when you look back at the history of
higher education in the United States
and the emphasis on the soviet union
after the Second World War you
understand why a place like Colombia had
a very strong Soviet Studies program and
why there is a Harriman Institute and of
course having that kind of financial
wherewithal over the years as well as
the possibility to hire professors to
teach about the Soviet Union meant that
there was a very large Soviet / Russian
presence at Columbia there was also at
all times practically any central
european presence at columbia these
central european programs started here
in 1954 and trained generations of
people who dealt at various universities
in the united states and beyond with the
issues of the time most of the most of
our colleagues were not terribly well
known because they weren't talking most
of the time about the soviet union well
that all changed after 1989 and in the
central european program here at
columbia now the two strongest pillars
are the hungarian and the polish pillars
and we're very happy to have this
constant presence if you will of
hungarians from hungry and from other
institutions coming to columbia to speak
about issues historical issues
and contemporary events of interest the
same thing goes to our polish colleagues
who came here and I think everybody
contributed to this debate very well we
had a strong presence of specialists on
the USSR and on Khrushchev and that was
a very obvious in the first panel that
we had yesterday our University Columbia
was very well represented by a large
group of people who contributed to the
discussion and indeed the planning of
this meeting we had a high-ranking
diplomat ambassador blinken begin our
session yesterday morning and we had
support from the institute for national
remembrance in Poland and the 1956
Institute in Budapest something that we
welcome and we will certainly be looking
for other kinds of institutional
cooperation with our partners there and
with other party on the point where
American institutions and foundations
are sending money to Europe and now
these central Europeans are beginning to
fund things in the United States and of
course the exhibits that we have
downstairs are proof of that the coastal
Foundation gave us money for this
conference as well I'd also like to
thank the audience for coming as you
probably have noticed 1956 is not
everybody's topic so we don't have for
example a lot of students in the
audience but I can assure you that there
are a lot of students looking at those
exhibits downstairs and maybe that will
have some kind of an impact on the next
generation of students that we have here
finally if you're worried that you
missed something yesterday or today
because you weren't in the room or you'd
like to have a further discussion about
something you'll be able to see the
Proceedings of this meeting on the web
so hopefully sometime before
Thanksgiving or maybe a little bit after
Thanksgiving our expert videographer
leuco Colleen each will have those those
things ready for us and we'll be able to
show all of that to you
online whenever you like so thank you
very much for coming and for those of
you who want to see the film downstairs
it will be starting very shortly you can
follow up professor Sanders to the 12th
floor